I can't advise psychobabble playing the
lunch with my main man Kanye and look at
the [ __ ] people up ok dad welcome
laughing good show ok we're at this fish
um ok that's why wait I didn't go there
flashback nothing good look I get it's
like a hate like I do not want to talk
to your bench mm-hmm ok do that sleep
right here why do everything in a
[ __ ] we're off ok good get this [ __ ]
done
all right Mara waiter than ever [ __ ]
now like my just I want to rather house
what what yeah well done well done wait
we're taking the leg yeah waiver were
taking a late shoulder mounted machine
gun the [ __ ] was the commissary up what
the [ __ ]
hm
ready to sell some things when he's
awesome misguided ahead now eight and
get rid of like jet and [ __ ] I don't
like that let me need that scotch I
can't cut
where is isn't beer doesn't I could do
anything okay where's the misc is where
the [ __ ] is then where's the junket
section here we go okay except how do I
not have like any money I feel like
since I've been playing this I've just
non-stop being just talking all the
money
dang of warheads over here anyone
perfect
great this I got back yes I can't sighs
that's all mmm hey that that you at
sestak hate that that's yeah I'll take
down I guess oh I don't know what imma
left on this thing
is there any more the things that I
could shoot no I guess not
okay [ __ ] oh there's one all right let's
make this interesting something done
writing now do they just got like pissed
off right do that look I get mad if I
was nice to cessation of hostilities
complete time to fight bad guys dealt
with yeah it's these guys oh this one
looks pretty telling what's that all
time to fight okay rate this [ __ ] Kanye
yeah fighting over mmm-hmm duffel bag to
mr a mess
is that explosive that can appear in on
it all all due respect sir I think
you're making a mistake we're close to a
break yes sir I am look
ok
yeah [ __ ] all right fine not that good
what's that all
okay sorry I mean a lot of Texas did I
remember to cut through that if not you
know what happened i forgot or I rest it
are you getting lot sausages I'd love
sausages especially when they're like so
bloody wait any more nukes or like that
whole nuke thing oh [ __ ] there's one
out of my way [ __ ] is wrong with this
guy gave my [ __ ] suit talking every
two seconds and that's like I'm going
[ __ ] nuts you're not talking nuts
like at home I'm gonna check out up
there real quick make sure there's no
[ __ ] I'll [ __ ] things I missing
desa they got a gun I got into done yeah
ignore what anyone says otherwise you
know like this as I got got I look like
I our way
no answer so you wanna say
that guy who are gonna pop here ouch
ouch [ __ ] [ __ ] aid
garrett 50 our bench okay well i'm
getting so [ __ ] up Oh stimpack gonna
be a doctor's bag
till that
ok I see the chef so I'm just [ __ ]
take them out wish I pistol I see
time to fight
was that all is there a [ __ ] okay
are we being watched I don't know it's
not talking bye okay
what why am i watching that special
someone oh yes
that's good
Oh
yeah sure
you